[Music]
Marco Polo is a deep learning computer
vision company we actually picked up one
of the hardest thing to do income
supervision which is fashion recognition
and time if I'm a female you know I
picked something that is relative to my
interest but actually there's a few more
reasons so fashion is actually the most
needed sector in computer vision
especially for visual search thank you I
mean just like any other search company
like Google or Baidu in the world they
are a text search company and we're
basically a visual search company so
there's different tiers of visual search
there's facial recognition which I
consider nowadays is not that hard to do
anymore it's really just a data problem
how much data you have and then above
that is product recognition so product
like a chair or or microphone all of
them have their distinct shape for for
each object you have to train for that
shape and then above object recognition
is actually deformable object
recognition which is fashion I was
wearing the jacket you know as I move
around the shape of the jacket change so
we actually end up picking something
much harder than facial recognition
harder than furniture recognition is
also one of the most needed because it's
very hard to describe fashion how do you
describe this jacket on Google like it's
extremely hard but it's much easier just
to submit an image and have computer
vision take care of it okay so deep
learning computer vision had a really
big breakthrough around end of 2015 and
beginning of 2016
I've known many many startups they're
trying to do product recognition
especially fashion recognition even from
like 7 years ago and all of them have
pivoted or felt because they did it too
early
like detection was not even there I
actually tried to build this technology
myself from scratch around John 14 and
realizes it's just so hard like the
accuracy is low that no one would use
this aren't you - I'm 15 and turns 16 I
ran across a few papers published in
cvpr if you guys know computer vision
there's like cvpr cumference icc VEC cv
so these conferences this world
scientists publish the latest findings
latest research so if you follow those
conferences you always find the latest
publication what is in a Singh and
through following those conferences I've
seen a few papers about recognizing
deformable fashion objects from a very
messy background at that time the
accuracy you guys know sensed I'm one of
the actually there's only two unicorn AI
her company in the world one of them is
cents time the other time is the other
one is meltwater and they're actually
more like machine learning company
they're all they're both like there are
probably the only two billion dollar
deep learning companies and same time I
published a paper their accuracy was 16%
that's Mitchell on 16 and now our
accuracy is 96% and you can ask me how
do I come up with the accuracy well we
we basically you have to test whether
it's accurate not especially subjective
so we we use a very objective way so if
we have the product in our database
finding that product from any random
image on the number one or number two
spot is 96% and that's about the highest
people ever seen so so far were the most
accurate fashion recognition company in
the world and we also just developed a
video recognition technology as well so
why we why we focus on video so video
has always been a focus it just like you
have to before your finished video you
have to finish image while we're doing
this today
you know the richest company in the
world right now they're divided one of
them is the content literal content
platforms we're talking about Netflix
YouTube they're getting all the eyeballs
because video traffic is gonna be 80% of
the Internet traffic by 2020 we're all
addicted and on the other side you know
there's Amazon there's all these retail
companies as you know they get the most
transactions so the content get most
eyeballs and the e-commerce gets most
transactions but the eyeballs guys the
the content ones they actually don't
have much revenue like even Netflix
they're throwing away like 2 billion a
year just buying contents from
everywhere they're not profitable at all
like most of these content platforms
they're losing money buying content just
there in the middle of spending money to
conquer the land and for the retailers
ecommerce they make a lot of they have a
lot of revenue but they don't have
enough eyeballs especially if you're not
Amazon everyone's trying to manage their
own platform even Macy's here you know
they're losing their revenue projection
they lost like 9 billion compared to the
previous year's in the last few years
they're all losing to Amazon's traffic
so how do we solve this problem we can
bring content more revenue and we can
bring rap ecommerce more eyeballs by
making advertising more organic so this
is the problem the mission of the
company we're basically saying on the
left is annoying us on the right is
organic ads that user initiatives so I
like this shirt I click on it and I can
buy it or even if I don't buy it the
fact that I see it is value so that's
like advertising called CP n versus CP s
so this is a quick experience I can
click on a button here and the products
will pop up as you seen the video I can
add the product to my shopping cart
and see other similar products also
using computer vision and finish the
checkout and thankfully today you know
we're in a stage where checkout
technology are very events and they're
all competing with each other their
strife there's Shopify Magento so you
can integrate with any one of them and
get a smooth experience because content
platform they don't want their traffic
to leak they don't just because they
want revenue it doesn't mean they want
you to see this product while watching a
TV show and then next moment you go to
Amazon they want you to stay on their
side so having a checkout piece is
actually crucial this is another
experience where you can pause the video
and then we show you not only will show
you where the actor is an actress you
know Amazon Prime they have a feature
called x-ray you pause the video you'll
see where the actors here is like we
call the x-ray for products not only you
see actress you can also see what
they're wearing okay so this is a quick
product demonstration this is our power
demo our technology work in the back
earlier you guys seen the application
first we started building the photo
recognition and our photo recognition is
using you know come by comparing the
feature vectors on the left to other
potted 8 abase we actually activate it
they help your brand's and total 5
million products from across the US you
make a signature for each one of them
like a future bacteria you can compare
and do a match and also we automatically
recognize the products from any given we
know the location of the product on the
image as well this is our Chrome
extension which you can download and
Shop any image you see on the Internet
it doesn't matter if you're on Google or
if you're on Pinterest
and this is our video recognition it's
built on top of photo but it's actually
a few more piece for example tracking
because video is basically moving
pictures but every second let's say
there's 96 frames you cannot treat video
like 96 images that means you have to
search 96 times every second it will
kill your system so here we added like
basically similar technology like
civilian camera you know we tracked the
product where it goes so we know exactly
in France that one 2005 is the same
product we're not searching it twice and
a wasted trip strategically pick a few
frames during that period and only
search once even if the Prada disappear
and reappear we'll still know that is
the same product and here's how its
application we're actually currently
working with one of the pic talks 6 year
company to make a short video shopping
app short video is now that the hardest
thing like the short video for videos
really keep your attention on your app
compared to long videos because people
get sync into one long video story but
when you're looking at short video you
you're never satisfied
15 seconds gone and now you're like what
next you can keep watching hundreds of
short videos and forget about time and
that's actually according to some
statistics in China tic toc is actually
a now becoming one of the biggest
company in China they actually are
winning by do even though tic toc sounds
like a commercial app but they have
thousands actually have 3,000 AI
computer vision scientists in the back
and most of them are video recognition
scientists they're not using video
recognition for shopping yet but they
use it for like changing the way you
look in the video making a look prettier
and some special effects things like
that hmm so I think for the biggest
problem for most AI company out there is
how to stay focused you know we have
really smart people in our team
but the smart researchers tend to say
yes to everything they will say yes I
can do this and yes I can do that I can
do anything so when you have five
clients and each one of the five clients
they can you do this they want different
things and most a I company even some
most famous AI companies out there will
say yes to all of them and try to
monetize all of them that's not a good
way like I think we've seen failures
from AI companies doing that the most
important thing is to stay focused and
you want to stay focused on a big market
not a small market we actually try to
have our image recognition just working
with retailers and then we realize that
market just too small because retailers
you know they don't pay that much and
then we realize you know what the rich
guys are a platform content platforms
they're spending billions of dollar
creating their own content why don't I
give them a new way to monetize the
content so this actually end up become
our current focus you want to make sure
you are serving the rich guys and you
know AI company is not a charity the
global market size and visual search
wins I mean I think for most investors I
mean we're all terrible investor what
they think about a company the number
one thing is are we in the right sector
is a sector of growing dramatically over
years sometimes they might not being
blessing you they might imagine in the
trend actually most sophisticated master
investing both the investing a person
and their investing in the sector is
growing really fast so the sector were
in wearing the digital video market and
digital video market every five year
there's like a new revolution and we're
betting on that we're gonna be the next
revolution
it used to be pre-roll you know you can
watch a hula show and then they'll stop
you for ten seconds every hour and this
is our current clients we have I want to
bore you with this we definitely way boy
is actually the Facebook of China so
we're working on making all their
celebrities photo and video shoppable
like me is actually the sister company
from tech child that were working with
we're still a true big company were
giving them our technology to launch so
so for big did an AI company what is the
most important thing is that revenue
I would say most a I company take a few
years to complete a product where you
can launch so before that you know
revenue is not sustainable you have to
focus on your KPI what is your KPI for
us our KPI is our search to purchase
rate and we have never changed if you
stay focused on your KPI then you can
worry less about revenue so this is the
especially in New York the New York
investor is always asking you what is
your revenue because they're all
financial background but the truth is
you're gonna be very firm and with them
you say we're a technology company and
revenue will come if our KPI is growing
at the same time you know another
problem that most air company encounter
is that how valuable is on my model
everyone every scientist think the model
they built is super valuable that no one
else has they don't want to give out to
anyone that when we work with really big
companies they want us they want our
model to run on their server because we
don't want it it's actually better for
startups as well because you feel wrong
the model on your server for these big
companies it will kill your costs the
AWS costs you know the cloud computing
cost is huge so what we learn is you
know your model is not that valuable
it's only a matter of time for any big
companies to know the ingredients your
model
the value is really the data so the more
you'll get out of the closet the higher
chance you can survive so we actually
willing to put our motto on any big
clients server in exchange for the data
because data is our lifeblood and how do
you be profitable
well most companies are not profitable
including the fortune 500 companies but
you have to aim for probabilities so one
of the thing I learned is like you know
you have to learn what is your cost of
goods sold and for us our cost of goods
so for AI company is computing cost you
know and also annotation cost and of
course talents but you can write talents
into R&D expenses because they are
research handling expenses if you're
cops if your cost of goods sold is
healthy that eventually you'll be
profitable so we actually learned to
lower our costs by moving away from
Cloud Servers I would say five years ago
everybody say stupid to have your local
machines and now we're actually moving
away from Cloud Servers just because
they're getting so expensive especially
AWS I mean I know Asia will give you a
free credit and Google will give you a
free credit because they're fighting for
the you know for the market AWS is of
vampire and we actually realized if we
run the same thing on local machine we
save the cost by we only spend about
one-sixth of the same cost for that
computation costs so now we're actually
doing the reverse strand moving
everything to machines and the
Challenger is a short cut of an AI
company I would say the biggest
challenge is infrastructure because you
know we start through a demo and to
build a demo you need AI scientist you
need engineers but can you launch the
technology was really big clients on the
scalable infrastructure and I realize
you know from being New York and
China hired really good infrastructure
talents for years those talents actually
much harder to hire than you know a PhD
a scientist because those kind of people
they're all reading big companies who
have the experience of handle really
scalable technology they're in big
companies getting paid at all for you to
be able to steal them and say hey we
don't have much traffic here to make
patchouli use but we think will
potentially have traffic in the future
is not that attractive so the shortcut
we find is actually try not to do
everything yourself
we partnered up with one of the biggest
video civilian camera infrastructure
company in China and they have
infrastructure in every single city and
we basically put our motto and wrong on
their parallel computing infrastructure
and that problem was solved you know I
have no idea you know how do I have to
spend ten million dollar to fix this so
there's a lot of thing you know try not
to do alone and thank you for the time I
think we're also hiring especially
infrastructure talents as you can hear
from me and also AI talents the company
is definitely expanding we rate
previously already raised six million
dollar we're closing another five
million right now so we're looking to
hire another five to seven really deep
AI talents and you have to have minimum
three to five years experience and
that's about it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]